first to keep track of its position in
the world that's correct
all of our entities and grits need to
know what position in the world they're
at for a number of reasons like physics
collision and rendering what about this
to know when it's time to die this is
actually not required not all entities
have a concept of time nor have a
concept of death for instance landmine
entities only live on the map for about
30 seconds
as such they need to know how long
they're staying around in life before
they explode other entities like the
spawners which will actually generate
energy canisters and health canisters
never die so they have no concept of
life or death they stick around until
the map is unloaded what about this one
to think or be able to do something each
tick this one is definitely a
requirement the definition of an entity
as we've discussed before is that you
have a class which contains some unique
logic that makes this entity different
from all the other ones in the world the
ability to think or have custom
processing associated with an entity is
critical to its definition
how about knowing what sounds to play
this is a little vague some entities
will need the ability to know and play
sounds during events for instance when a
rocket hits the wall we would hope that
it plays it's explosion sound the player
for instance may not need to know any
sounds because the environment is making
sounds on their behalf and finally what
about the need to post to your Google+
stream this is more of wishful thinking
on my part but in reality you shouldn't
be coding in the ability to do HTTP
requests to each one of the entities in
your game although you should definitely
check out this place I hear it's cool